but i just think you need to throw out
all those playbooks because like you
said
what made sense in the past it's not
gonna make sense in the future
and when kind was born i was this far
away
from the tower people have all these
perceptions having watched it now for 10
years people have grown up with it
but when you came on the set for the
first time what was not as expected for
[Music]
you
well tell me let's talk a little bit
about uh kind because a lot of my
followers don't know
how this whole thing started why don't
you give me some background on
you know obviously you're a shark now so
you did something right
i'm not quite like mr wonderful but
trying to learn from you kevin
so the story of kind is prior to kind
ten years before after finishing law
school i started a company
called peace works to bring neighbors
together israelis are
and across the world that used to use
business as a force
for trying to create catalyst ventures
with neighbors
so the idea was to get peace in the
middle east which nobody's been able to
achieve yet right
and use business as a force for breaking
stereotypes and cementing relations and
giving people
a profitable interest in maintaining
those
uh relations and it became a food
company and it was not the biggest
company
you know the biggest success it was two
steps forward two steps back
10 years of mistakes but along the way
i had the idea for a healthy snack that
i could feel good about eating on the go
and i was trying to solve for my own
needs because i was
crisscrossing the country trying to sell
our products or going across or
skipping lunch or dinner while i was in
the office or on the go
um i felt like i wanted a snack that i
could feel good about eating and
uh the idea for kind came to me and we
launched it and then it became uh
what it became it's one of the things
let's talk about the metrics of kind
because
i mean for all the shark tank fans out
there how many points of distribution
does kind have i see it everywhere
it's it's our best guess because
sometimes we use distributors and stuff
but it's probably
maybe northwards of 300 000 points okay
that's
i mean that's everybody's dream to get a
product into 300 000
outlets i mean i mean that's just
incredible you know
i think at the end of the day um that's
power of distribution
should be able to help you you know if
you when you come back to shark tank on
friday
you're back tomorrow i mean in the back
of your mind when you're listening to
deals are you thinking about the power
of distribution you have
um i do but you know very often when
people interview me they're like
how did you get your distribution tell
me about your secrets for distribution
and yes it requires a lot of great and
hard work to
think creatively and knock on doors so
there's a lot of
work to get that but i think the number
one secret
is just have a killer product because if
you have the best product that really
really
the distribution follows now there's a
lot of inertia right because
the established players have that so you
need to take that from them
so it does take a lot of work but
ultimately in our
industry of the consumer product goods
you know product is king whereas maybe
in finance
cash is king i think when you have a
superior
product it ultimately it might take a
while but it ultimately gets that
distribution
how challenging is it when you have a
you know we get so many food products on
shark tank
and my big beef with it is there's no
free shelf space for any new products
it's already
full of products with behemoth companies
they're not interested in having some
newcomer take some shelf space from an
end cap which is very expensive to even
buy or maintain
isn't that the hardest thing even to get
a chance to get a little bit of shelf
space because when you're a tiny little
snack cockroach how are you ever going
to get any space from the behemoths that
control it
well and sadly that specific challenge
kevin
is now so much greater today like that's
one of the
pain points of covid because retailers
just need to keep their shelves
full they need to keep their supply
chains flowing
and the small guys which i still
consider myself even though we're now
a multi-billion dollar company but i at
my heart and that
guy barely was surprised to meet payroll
i was born out of some of the darkest
moments of my life
not just in terms of business but in
terms of like
i had just lost my dad and i had a lot
of other challenges so i
always feel like i'm that guy and for
everyone that's starting to launch a new
product this is not the right
environment
because it's all about having good
supply chains that are redundant and
that favors the big guys so
for the last decade or two the small
guys have been
basically winning more and more and more
market share from the
size that were entrenched but not as
innovative
the supply chains of the bigger better
established companies
have gained back some of that share
because the small guys
don't have redundant supply chains don't
have if one of their factories goes down
one team members sick and they have to
close down
for a couple of weeks to reclaim they
lose all their sales and it's a very
tricky environment
buyers are not reviewing your products
right now so let's go
let's talk about your shark tank
experience i mean this is not your first
time
on shark tank this is uh you know you're
a bit of a veteran now
what was a surprise to you because
people have all these perceptions having
watched it now for 10 years people have
grown up with it
but when you came on the set for the
first time what was not as expected for
you
so i'll tell you two things first how
real it is like
he was you know my kids and i
and my wife we love watching shark tank
i love using
shark tank to then ask the kids what do
you think about this and for them
to learn entrepreneurship it's a really
fun show for us to watch
i was stunned at how real it is like
people ask me what's mr wonderful like
in real life
you see what you see is what you get you
guys are really real like
very much you know you're actually a
little bit sweeter than you let on
[Music]
don't let that secret out daniel are you
kidding um you could destroy my
reputation
i'm a confused mexican jew but i have a
connection with israel and israelis they
call them sabras because
outside they have spikes but when you
open up the fruit is very sweety
very sweet that's who you remind me of
but um
but for the most part your personality
you're very straightforward
laurie is very nurturing mark is very
you know
to the point uh robert's very empathetic
damon's very
prepared like every one of you guys what
you see on tv is what you get and you do
not get
any preparation um it's enormously
challenging because you have to keep up
with all these inputs but my greatest
surprise
was how you stole two deals from me
right from right i don't know if you
remember but like
we laurie and i twice and the pain is
that once it broadcast
then you remember all those feelings we
were about to get a deal and then you
came from down under and you're there so
if i'm back believe me i'm not gonna let
that happen again
i take the challenge you throw the
gauntlet down i'm ready anytime buddy
i'm looking forward to all the new ideas
that are being created while people sit
in quarantine
all over america there's going to be
fantastic new ideas
all kinds of new problems to be solved
with new entrepreneurs i think
you know i'm very optimistic always but
we get out of this mess we're in
america is going to be more efficient
than ever and there'll be new ways of
doing business maybe
people work at home more who knows all
the changes that are going to occur but
i don't know about you i'm looking
forward to getting back there
and seeing all the new ideas and
investing in them that's the best part
don't you think
um i i like you um in
awe of the entrepreneurial spirit and
the creativity and the staying power
of entrepreneurs and you know there's
things in this very
painful experience that we learn on
silver linings about
like you said online marketing
online shopping online delivery uh
digital experiences working from home
there's a lot of things that i think
we're going to learn and
hopefully we're going to take this
crisis as an opportunity to figure out
how our society and our community can
actually
become better from it and it was painful
um but you know fundamentally yeah i am
a very big believer and as i was hinting
earlier kevin when kind was born
i was this far away from um in the towel
because literally we just lost a million
dollars
we were at two million dollar business
and we had lost under those two million
dollars
because we had uh one product that was
importing and we had to control over
the manufacturer added artificial
ingredients that we can do in the
in the natural stores and we literally
went around the table and said should we
try this again and create our own brand
what became kind
or should we just close this and nobody
kevin would have faulted us
for closing and giving up at the time it
had been 10 years of effort
i could not pay myself a salary and then
we tried it
and it became what it became and you
never
i would have never imagined you know
back in 2003 2004 well you only need one
great idea to change your life and
certainly done that for you
i want to do an open invitation you
daniel because i get thousands of
questions
on my youtube channel called ask mr
wonderful about launching new food
products
and i think it's extremely difficult so
what i'd like to do is get you on as a
guest host
and talk about just that what does it
take to launch a new
you know you could do beverage and
snacks because ever i'm always getting
somebody saying oh i got this fantastic
new
snack i'm right now i'm living through
the experience with bohana which is pop
lily seeds water lily seeds
it sells very well direct and i sold it
on qvc this week and we sold 107
more than the target but distribution in
retail
is an absolute [ __ ] it's so difficult
and so i want to bring you on as a guest
you could tell me what a what a
cockroach i am that'll be great
everybody talk about cockroaches in a
different frame but
i would be very honored to be on your
youtube channel my kids
were challenging me that how pathetic it
is that they
have more followers on youtube i think i
have three followers because we just
opened our youtube channel
daniel lubetsky i have three subscribers
and they're like if you will have me on
your youtube channel i'll be honored but
uh
well look i'll help you out a little bit
there i hope so that's going to be my
open invitation
so i'm looking forward to seeing you
tomorrow night on shark tank
and uh i think it's pride we're
tomorrow sorry i'm confused it's friday
night i don't even know anymore which
day of the week it is they're all the
same to me
it's like groundhog day there's one
tomorrow because it's the next to last
and then
friday is the finale and i think it's
going to be the best one of the season
the season finished i'm looking forward
to it i always loved to see how they
edited it you were there you know the
pitches can be 10 20 30 minutes long
but only seven minutes makes it to
television so i think they do a
masterful job because i really enjoy
seeing because i always remember the
products
all of them every single one that's ever
been on there it's it's
you know it's crystal clear and i
remember you know some of the deals you
were involved in were 25 minutes
it was a long debate but i have to tell
you i
am in all of you guys because i recorded
for one day in june
and one day in september and when we
finished that day and
start seven a.m and go all the way to
like seven p.m
and i finished the day exhausted
depleted
and it takes me three or four days to
just
decompress and digest oh my god i should
have come back to mr wonderful
with that
you're very witty you're very fast but
not only that
how do you guys do it because you record
not one day like i did
you do like 10 14 days straight for how
do you keep it together it is
stunning it really is not easy i i'm how
do you don't get exhausted like a mouth
and i'm very impressed with you guys
well
i i think i think we do get exhausted
but we love the entrepreneurs that keep
us energized
i'm hoping this year we don't know it's
going to be so different with all these
new ideas they're going to be
it's not people aren't going to be
coming out daniel saying i have another
retail idea anymore
it's going to be much more direct to
consumer i think because retail's under
amazing challenge
and puts big guys like you at a huge
advantage you already establish
distribution
as it opens up you're going to be there
but you know i'll just give a shout out
to kind bar
i never eat a lot of snacks because i'm
always trying to control my weight so
every time i grab them
you were very kind to send me some bars
and i eat one every day now sometimes
too because i read the calories
you've done a great job making them
tasty with good stuff
and low calories high protein low
calories that's all i give a [ __ ] about
i want low calories
so keep up the good work on that let me
challenge you on the
cal yes low calories is useful but more
useful is the quality of the calories
if you got a low calorie but it's empty
calories without nutrition it's not good
you want to look for nutritionally dense
ingredients like
if if your calories are coming from
almonds that are heart healthy and brain
beneficial
it's very different if it's just from
like look
i love the what like i've tried so many
different flavors obviously and i have
my favorites but
anything with nuts with low calories i
feel i mean i'm doing something healthy
for myself
and i don't want a lot of sugar like
that i think you've done a masterful job
and i wouldn't say that
if i didn't believe it it's the only
snack i carry around with me now
because when you really have that you
know you miss lunch or something
and i always say i'll just eat half but
i eat the whole damn thing
let's send mr wonderful more product
please
[Laughter]
what you said i want to ask you a
question
but real quickly on your prior point
distribution
yes i do think we have an advantage but
i just think you need to throw out all
those playbooks because like you said
what made sense in the past it's not
going to make sense in the future
so every entrepreneur right now it's a
great opportunity for them
to completely think about it as horrible
as it is
all the rules have changed so there's a
space for entrepreneurs to fill it up
without the entrenched
power of the prior players and to
completely disrupt the industry with all
of the stuff
like you said there will be a lot of
people that
are going to be able to see something
that others didn't see because the
space has changed so much well that's
very optimistic to say
and i'm looking forward to seeing
exactly what that's going to be i think
innovation is always disruptive and
that's okay
but anyways daniel thank you for your
time today i'm inviting you to the ask
mr wonderful
and i want to meet your kids when we do
that too one question to you
yeah but you have to say the truth
uh you are like so fast like and you
and you talk about you know about
everything and sometimes you're joking
about it but you actually have
a big store of knowledge
how does it really come to you and do
you pre-plan it do people
send you ideas like how do you come up
with like such
facts i i i say the reason and here's my
answer to that
when i was young just like you i had
some international experiences my fault
my original father died when he was 36 i
was only
eight years old and my mother remarry um
george my stepfather who was graduating
from the university of champaign-urbana
university of illinois in
champaign-urbana he took a job with
united nations
and for the rest of my life i moved to a
new country every two years
all through my youth cyprus cambodia
tunisia ethiopia japan
germany france and i just thought that's
how
everybody lived and so it was sort of
learning new stuff in new
societies and new places and you know i
became a
an assistant to a a chemi rouge
french asian chef tea vendang were their
names and that's how i learned to cook
but i used to go at five in the morning
to the market
to make in the mekong delta and eat live
snails i thought everybody did that
but i think it was a great education and
i think a lot of that has stuck with me
and it's been very useful on shark tank
it's hard to both it's really hard to
[ __ ] me daniel it really is
i know it's very impressive i i'm like
how does she know that stuff and
but also you're like fast you guys all
of you you come up with these
things i'm like how did they do it i
guess well you know i've looked at a lot
of deals
but look i'm that that invitation is
open and bring bring one
when we do the shoot let's have one of
your kids around that would be fun just
for them to say hi on the youtube
channel
if you like that video wait did you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe